I said this is proof one okay this is
rather a blunt instrument to use first
principles right we tend to use first
principles boy I don't know what else we
can do okay but there's another way to
do this and it is rather more elegant
but it's sort of simpler and faster but
I wanted you to understand this because
this is actually the real stuff I want
you to get okay remember I said because
it could be anything it could be
anything therefore we have to use
principles that work within any function
at any derivative and therefore we draw
a conclusion account better use I better
use first principles cuz it work with
anything right but actually I kind of
sneakily avoided the fact that you do
know other principles that will work
with any function for instance if I
showed you a function which was the
product of two other functions right it
doesn't matter what those other
functions are they could be anything and
you can still use the product rule on
this guy all right use the product rule
in the same way if I had u divided by V
I could use the question rule no matter
what u and V are okay so per true
Christian rule these are all just rules
apply to anything right there's one more
that you guys know about you know a
chain rule now why do I go to chain rule
and make you think about that well see
this is and see this they are in fact
functions or functions did you see that
right for example here this is a
function X but this is a function of
negative x right under negative is not
very complicated but it's a different
function right so I've got functions of
functions have happening here okay so
I'm going to take advantage of that I'm
gonna start again
I just want F - right - I know the crew
scuse me but the definition of F - is
feedback to my notation with
it's F and I differentiate that let me
slap a differential operator on the
front de on DX okay with that but by
definition remember right because f is
odd instead of writing f of X I can
write if I come back to sky oh yeah
f of X here is if I multiply both sides
by negative one it's minus f of minus x
do you agree with that like I just got
that straight from here and I multiply
both sides I'll quickly finish okay
don't worry went to me low so I'm going
to substitute F for that guy that guy
right there okay so that's minus F of
minus X are you happy just a
substitution and I look carefully I'm
differentiating something is a constant
India what's the difference between say
the derivative of x cubed and the
derivative of say a hundred X cube
what's the difference between those yeah
it's just multiplied by a hundred in
fact this is just a hundred or the other
one right do you remember this one which
established the rules of differentiation
right at the beginning if you have a
constant coefficient you just pull them
out I have a constant coefficient namely
negative one so I can pull them out
how'd it go and now I'm ready to
differentiate that's um that's a
function of a function so when I do the
function in function do the inside and
then I do the outside inside then
outside okay I've got a minus sign or a
hang on the front what's the derivative
of that inside function it's negative
one what's the duty of the outside
function well the outside function is f
so therefore its derivative is f dash
that's that's all it is I don't know
what that is right that's all I can say
so it's M dash of minus X don't forget
it is still minus X right hold on I have
some negatives to cancel right
what am I got in left I've got f - what
have I got on right f
maybe an X the derivative is either